[Music]
hun I think there's someone stealing our
trash cans oh no that's just the guy
from Kermit calm it's not my service
that rolls your cans to the curb on
garbage day only $14.99 a month well
that seems pretty pricey babe everyone
knows that time is money so we're
actually saving money by not doing
chores ourselves that's why I've got em
start delivering your groceries or over
walking the dog washio doing our laundry
and TaskRabbit cleaning the gutters well
I guess that'll give us more time to
write this episode no need I already
hired a radio to finish the episode for
us really wow that's really meta the
convenience economy is nothing new ever
since the Industrial Revolution first
world families have been willing to
cough up our turn dough to spend less
time on household chores the confining
hours around the water tub are a thing
of the past until recently that meant
gadgets and appliances but the Internet
has ushered in a new kind of convenience
on-demand services that quickly match
clients with freelancers who will do
just about anything the on-demand
industry is one of the fastest growing
in the world transportation and food
delivery are still the biggest sectors
but new services in areas like home and
pet care are popping up all the time
there's even a service that matches you
with goats in your area who will come by
and trim your lawn
oh we're totally doing it's an economy
driven not just by technology but
changing social demographics not too
long ago it was standard for every
household to have one full-time employee
who took care of the vast majority of
household chores and all for free thanks
mom but unpaid work is still work and
since more women have entered the
workforce it makes sense that we're
starting to assign dollar values to the
tasks most of us got to take for granted
so how do you know whether you can
afford to outsource your tours
when considering one of these on the
and services the first question you need
to ask yourself is whether this is
leverage or luxury leverage is more like
an investment let's say that by hiring a
lawn service you save yourself two hours
of yard work and you invest that time
into your side business screen printing
t-shirts to sell on Etsy like the
responsible side hustler you are you've
already calculated that you make about
$25 a profit for every hour you put in
and since the lawn service costs $40
congratulations you've successfully
leveraged your money to make more money
in other words as long as you're able to
make more per hour than what you're
paying someone else you're coming out
ahead but let's say that's not an option
for you maybe you work 40 hours a week
with no overtime and no side hustle then
you're likely outsourcing chores for a
different reason to free up personal
time to do stuff you actually like that
puts this surface into the luxury
category luxuries are not necessarily
bad things but they are harder to judge
economically because you can't really
put a dollar value on me-time but one
thing's for sure no luxury is worth
going into debt over so that's what
you've got to mind the gap if any
outsourcing service pushes your monthly
expenses above your monthly income
you'll have to forego it or find some
other place to cut back that means
you'll need a clearer idea of how much
these services actually cost and some of
them aren't very transparent grocery
delivery services like instacart are
clear about their delivery fees but they
also charge hidden markups on many items
that are constantly fluctuating there's
no way to know how much extra you're
paying without going down to the store
at a price check but that kind of
defeats the purpose doesn't it one
instacart user actually did the math and
posted his results on reddit turns out
he paid an average of 42 point eight
percent markup including some items that
cost well more than double their
in-store price when you factor in the
service and delivery fees he spent
almost 70 bucks not to go to the
supermarket that might be I'm a high end
of the spectrum but
is the easier these services are to use
the less likely we are to keep track of
the costs when you pay a cab driver in
cash so very aware of the value of that
ride but with uber you could just get
out of the car and walk away
depending on how you approach it the
on-demand economy can be a solid
investment a path to more freedom or if
you're not careful a financial ball and
chain that could drag you deeper into
debt we often recommend that saving for
retirement should take priority over
present comfort because there will come
a day when you really won't be able to
mow your own lawn or shop for your own
groceries and you want to be able to
afford those services then and as our
two cents
you
[Music]